hallo mein name ist luca um meine lieben
freunde wir sind heute unterwegs auf der
langweiligsten website der welt
meine video ideen werden echt immer
besser der einzig und dann einige sind
dieser website besteht darin dass man
auf diesen knopf hier klicken dann
bringt einen die website auf irgend eine
langweilige website
krazy kart trick ganz im ernst dieser
trick wird dein gehirn wegsprengen start
weg ging es nun also sollen ihre farbe
auswählen ich nunmal herz wenn ihr jetzt
eine richtung ok links jetzt sollen wir
uns nur im kopf eine karte von denen
hier aussuchen die website kann gern
nicht hören deswegen sage ich euch
einfach könig kreuz den sekunden später
ich glaube die website hört mich doch
allerdings habe jetzt die möglichkeit
dass wir oben rechts wieder auf den
button klicken und wie gelangen direkt
zur nächsten website gästen
incorrect liga ist 21.000 teil warte mal
was
wir sollen einen pin erraten 1 2 3 4
1 2 3 5
jetzt schon mal 21 1029 mal ich mache
noch einmal und zwar das hier
natürlich website machen allerdings
direkt weiter mit der nächsten webseite
die da lautet geo kitten can your choice
and industry review of the decade kippen
[Musik]
die website lebt nicht richtig es wird
immer besser hier auf meinem kanal von
daher weiter mit der nächsten website
wir haben eine trompete
ich habe gerade meine zweite
die dritte prüfung vom finanzamt und
ich freue mich jetzt schon darauf den
erklären zu müssen was mein beruf ist
diese website meine damen und herren wir
haben schere stein papier okay ich nehme
schere
stein ich hab verloren okay ich bin mir
noch mal ich die website lädt nicht mehr
bitte youtube warum habt ihr nicht
einfach durchgezogen einen kanal
gelöscht habe aber mich braucht man
wirklich nicht auf dieser plattform egal
leute nächste website die metric world
day when do you turn 10.000 wann wann
werde ich 10.000 jahre hat ja
wahrscheinlich gar nicht ich gebe trotz
von meinen geburtstag 1 und 2 der 21
februar 1996
ließ mich verarschen keine dieser
webseiten funktioniert länger als zehn
sekunden auch man ist scheint okay forge
intel extreme ich kann kein englisch
schon da machen wir direkt weiter mit
der nächsten website die vielleicht gar
nicht liegt doch bobby mc but don't
puppen die tolle bunte kreis
nature des best
of one likes of art unless you for some
reason like for zum ein gott bestimmt
eine ganz große sache ich weiß mich der
schlüssel hört mich trotzdem noch alle
aber findet ihr es auch manchmal ganz
schön liegt wenn ihr vor zu lande daran
riecht
nächster website meine damen und herren
inherent lief an
dass das
das sind taschentücher die man aus dem
arsch einer katze raus das bestätigt
mich direkt
an der elbe
perfekt mit diesem comfortline kann man
sich den arsch besser ab wird das was
braucht die heiratet water kann man hier
kaufen also einfach
luft
ich liebe diese webseiten speichern
statement under pence also unterwäsche
die hände eine ketchup kann ob ich darf
ihn sogar zeit nicht weiter angucken das
wäre alles die geburtstagsgeschenke für
meine freundin den nächsten 20 jahren
seien von drei mal direkt weiter mit der
nächsten website oder die user des
website heißt die die liste einem
einfach ohne tiger webseiten auf
und das ist ja genau mein humor and
resorts das hatten wir sogar schon mal
haben wir hier
[Musik]
ist mein computer und haben wir auch
noch jetzt das hatten wir auch schon mal
da kann man im film drehen
die website hatten wir auch schon mal
irgendwie content echt ziemlich
eingleisig man das wort existiert koall
us to the max haben wir auch noch als
website keine ahnung was da jetzt
passiert wir haben also
das hatte ich doch auch schon mal
gemacht kommt dann irgendwann
leben scheiße direkt weiter zur nächsten
website von der ual find yourself
machen wir direkt weiter mit der
nächsten website meine lieben freunde
und zwar lädt wieder nicht
doch generate poster okay wir können den
text schreiben ich mache einfach mal der
standard begrüßung hallo mein name ist
luca dass wir tatsächlich in köln auch
bald in meinem dings stehen in meinem
aufnahme zimmer stehen sonst hätten
neonschrift zu kriechen an die wand was
ist das jetzt
ich kreiere hier gerade mein eigenes
waschgel ich dachte ich mache ein poster
aber es geht um das poster für das
waschgel
von daher machen wir direkt weiter mit
der nächsten website und zwar ob wir
haben auch das habe ich vor lange nicht
mehr gespielt wir müssen mit q w
allerdings bewegen und picasso und das
ist
0,5 meter die wir es geschafft haben
probieren was nochmal ich war eine
zeitlang richtig gut drin jetzt
allerdings
lassen wir haben nächste website meine
damen und herren wir haben einfach
[Musik]
ja das würde ich jetzt verkaufen zehn
millionen euro ließ die website die wir
uns heute anschauen welcome to dig s
messe
peters messer hallo mein name ist luca
trick kopie url
man kann ich irgendwas
reinschreiben einfach und dann steht es
hier das nennt sich dann einfach wird
jetzt selbst die wir uns anschauen ist
can you go perfekt
okay das ist interessant also die circle
around das
ach so
der abstand muss
ich schaffe es bei dem malen eines
kreises in die falsche rekord aber
getrennt
[Musik]
ich bin zu langsam dies website meine
damen und herren wie im euro
ok
ich kann
das ist das jetzt letzte website für
heute damen und herren sohn let's get
started the game
muss ich jetzt
zwei stunden später und die letzten 3 2
1 wir haben dürfen meldet henning über
das vor
57 36
das sind ihr meditieren
dass ich jeden einzelnen verdammten
schalter für euch da gerade umgelegt
habe geklickt habe einfach auf den
screen geguckt haben überhaupt nicht
mehr zitiert habe
wirklich das
war wieder ein wahnsinns video